today i'm speaking on behalf of millions
of people in afghanistan
whose fate hangs in the balance and are
faced with an extremely uncertain future
i'm speaking for millions of affluent
girls and women who are about to lose
their freedom to go to school
to work and to participate in the
political economic and social life of
the country
i'm speaking for thousands of human
rights defenders journalists academics
civil servants and former security
personnel whose lives are at risk for
defending human rights and democracy
i'm speaking for thousands of internally
displaced people who are desperately in
need of shelter food and protection in
kabul and other places
as you're witnessing yourself the
situation in kabul a city of about 6
million people is extremely worrying to
say the least
you have seen chaotic scenes at the
kabul international airport as desperate
citizens are trying to leave the country
mr president
we are extremely concerned about
taliban's not honoring their promises
and commitments made in their statements
at doha and at other international
forums
we've witnessed time and again how
taliban have broken their promises and
commitments in the past
we have seen gruesome images of
taliban's mass executions of military
personnel and target killings of
civilians in kandahar and other big
cities
mr president
we cannot allow this to happen in kabul
which has been the last refuge for many
people escaping violence and taliban's
revenge attacks
kabul residents are reporting the
taliban have already started house to
house searches in some neighborhoods
registering names and looking for people
in their target list
there are already reports of target
killings and looting in the city
kabul residents are living in absolute
fear right now
mr president
there is no time for blame game anymore
we have an opportunity to prevent
further violence
prevent afghanistan descending into a
civil war and becoming a pariah state
therefore the security council and the
u.n secretary general should use every
means at its disposal to call for an
immediate secession of violence and
respect for human rights and
international humanitarian
law call on the taliban to fully respect
the general amnesty offered by them
cease target killing and revenge attacks
and abide by international humanitarian
laws
urge that no public institutions and
service delivery
infrastructure be demolished including
works of arts in museums and media
institutions
stressed that anyone violating human
rights of afghan citizen and
international humanitarian law will be
held accountable
urgently establish a humanitarian
corridor for the evacuation of those at
risk of taliban's retributions and
attacks
call on neighboring countries of
afghanistan to open their borders and
facilitate exit of people trying to
escape an entry of goods for
humanitarian relief and operations
call for the immediate establishment of
an inclusive and representative
transitional government that includes
all ethnic groups and women
representatives which can lead to a
dignified and lasting solution to the
conflict bring peace and preserve the
gains of the last 20 years especially
for women and girls
stress
that the council and the united nations
will not recognize any administration
that achieves power through force or any
government that is not inclusive and
representative of its diversity
of the country
unequivocally state that it does not
recognize the restoration of the islamic
emirate as reinformed in previous
council statements and agreements
establish international guarantees for
the implementation of a future political
agreement
and finally mobilize urgent humanitarian
assistance for the 18 million people of
afghanistan particularly those displaced
by current conflict the u.n humanitarian
appeal at 1.3 billion dollars remain 40
percent funded we urge the international
community to meet the remainder of this
life-saving appeal to provide critical
aid to all internally displaced people
at the end i would like to thank the
united nations and many other
international organizations who are on
the ground providing life-saving
humanitarian support and monitoring
human rights on the ground thank you mr
president